الجلد هو أكبر عضو في جسم الإنسان ،
كل بوصة مربعة مليئة بـ 19
مليون خلية ، وهنا في كوريا الجنوبية
يتم التعامل مع هذه الخلايا في بعض
أكثر طرق دفع الحدود جذريًا على
هذا الكوكب ، وكل ذلك في مهمة واحدة
للحفاظ على بشرتك مثالية  إلى الأبد ، كل هذا
جزء من k-beauty ،
فهذه Alicia Yoon هي ساحرة جمال k
ومؤسس أحد مواقع التجميل الأكثر نفوذاً في البلاد وأكثر
ما أحبه
في سيول هو أنك تشعر
وكأن المدينة حية ، وعادة ما تكون المنتجعات الصحية
مفتوحة 24  / 7 ولا يشبه الأمر إلى حد كبير
أن كل شيء مفتوح حتى وقت متأخر أو 24 ساعة ،
ولكن هناك أيضًا
صخب وضجيج حول المدينة ، حيث يبدو أن هناك
نوعًا حقيقيًا من روح ريادة الأعمال
هنا مثل الرغبة في
الحياة ، وهناك فكرة أن الحفاظ على
حياتك  الجلد ليس شيئًا
تفعله مرة واحدة فقط وقد انتهيت منه ، إنه عضو ،
إنه عضو ثمين جدًا
لسوق الجمال العالمي من المتوقع أن
يصل إلى ثمانمائة وخمسة مليارات دولار
بحلول عام 2023.  ليست
هذه الفكرة حقًا أنه يجب أن تكوني
خالية من العيوب وجميلة جدًا ، لكنها
في الواقع جزء من الرعاية الذاتية في حين أن العديد
منا لديه طبيب أسرة أو طبيب أسنان ،
كما أن العديد من الكوريين لديهم أيضًا أخصائي تجميل للعائلة
أتيت لرؤيتها  مع أمي
مع جدتي مع خالتي وهي
خبيرة تجميل رائعة لذا فهي
تعرفني منذ أن كنت صغيرًا جدًا وأنت
تعرف شخصًا لديه عملاء فقط
على المدى الطويل لديك نوعًا من
هذه التجربة حقًا كل المعرفة التي
يمكنك  لا أحب التعلم مما ورد أعلاه ، أليس
الأمر رائعًا ، لذا فإن أبطالي بحاجة إلى المساعدة ،
لذا ما سنفعله هو
أن وجوهك تفقد الكثير من المرونة التي تجعلها
حقيقية ، ولكن إذا كنت تزور كوريا للتو
وليس لديك عائلة  خبير تجميل الوجه
أحد أكثر الأماكن شهرة لتجربة
جمال k
هو أن روابط الزنجبيل jimjilbang هي
مهنة غنائية شهيرة بالنسبة لي شخصيًا.
فندق
مثل أماه  منازل الحمامات في نيويورك مفتوحة على مدار 24
ساعة وتقدم كل شيء من الفحم إلى
حمامات البخار المالحة على بعد مسافة قصيرة عبر
نهر هان ، معمل جلدي هنا ، حيث
يمارسون بعض الأساليب المبتكرة في
العناية الشخصية بالبشرة ، أول شيء
تفعله هو تحليل بشرتك.
أنك تعرف بالضبط العلاجات التي
تحتاجها بشرتك على وجه التحديد ، فهذا هو المكان
الذي سيحدث فيه السحر ،
قد يبدو هذا المكان وكأنه منشأة طبية
ولكنه في الواقع مختبر مخصص
لإكمال البشرة وهذا الشيء هنا
يتعلق بجهاز رش الجراح إنه
مريح للغاية  وبحلول نهاية
العلاج ، اختفت الحقيبة بالكامل وفي
وجهك حان الوقت لبعض
بيلاتيس الوجه ، لا يؤذي هذا الشعور ولكن هذا
الشعور المثير للاهتمام لأن
عضلاتك تتدرب
بطريقة لا تستخدمها  بالنسبة للكثير من
عملائهم سيأتون إلى هنا مرة واحدة في الأسبوع ، الأمر
يشبه الذهاب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية ،
إنه مثل الحفاظ على
بشرتك ، يُنظر إلى فكرة رعاية بشرتك بانتظام
على أنها ضرورة  بدلاً من
التساهل وربما لا يوجد مكان آخر
في كوريا
أنت